on in our road to a vaccine series we're
going to take a look at operation warp
speed the trump administration's
unprecedented effort
to accelerate production and distribute
distribution rather of a covey vaccine
still think about wendy
the nearly 10 billion program is already
producing tens of millions of vaccine
doses
even before we know which vaccine
candidates can be proven safe and
effective
in a rare interview retired lieutenant
general paul ostrowski
director for supply production and
distribution shares how they're tackling
what he calls a herculean task
without sacrificing the safety he spoke
to our dr tara narula
operation works speed's stated goal is
to produce
and deliver 300 million doses of safe
and effective coveted vaccines to
americans with the initial doses
available
by january 2021. are you on target
to accomplish that mission absolutely we
are actually going to exceed that
expectation
we will have vaccines we anticipate
prior to the turn of the new year
you will have 300 million doses prior to
the new year
now we will start off with a lower
amounts
and over time gradually build to that
when should the general population
expect to be able to get a vaccine
it will probably be a prioritization
based
schedule we would expect that by the
first quarter and the first quarter
early second quarter of next year it's
called operation
warp speed that means big and it means
fast
many americans are concerned when they
hear operation warp speed
that somehow there's going to be a
compromise in terms of safety
we've gone through the same trial
process as any other drug or vaccine
ever has
and the amount of fda oversight
and the approval process with the fda is
just like
any other drug or any other vaccine it
is unprecedented with respect to the
speed
we are taking absolutely positively no
shortcuts with respect to safety or
efficacy
what challenges do you foresee in
getting a vaccine to americans
well at least one of them is a cold
chain vaccine in other words the storage
it has to be kept fairly cold and we're
working with that particular
pharmaceutical company in order to get
further studies as to how long it can be
frozen and how long it can stay in a
refrigerator or how long it can be at
room temperature
will the vaccine be free for all
americans
absolutely 110 percent free no
out-of-pocket costs
how will the vaccine be paid for well
simply the government has already bought
the vaccines
and the government has already paid for
the distribution of the vaccines the
trade association that represents state
immunization managers has asked congress
for 8.4 billion dollars to help
distribute the vaccine
will states receive sufficient federal
funds to be
able to distribute a vaccine absolutely
we've already distributed 200 million
another 140 will be passed out soon as
we've got these
plans now back from the states we
understand what their challenges are and
what they need there was a shortage of
both ppe
and testing supplies especially early on
in the pandemic
can you assure the american people that
the distribution of the vaccine
will go more smoothly absolutely tara
and this is why
we've got billions of needles billions
of syringes uh
here in the united states that we're
putting together in kits
and we were going to ship those kits in
addition to the vaccines
to an administration site the trump
administration has compared operation
work speeds program
to the notoriously secret government
project to make the first
atomic bomb unlike anything our country
has seen
since the manhattan project what would
you say to your critics who worry that
your program
may not be transparent we have been as
transparent as we possibly can do you
have to
come together as a as a whole of america
approach with our
our industry partners and get after the
hard things looking at
what are the key factors wearing on the
problem
so what we're trying to do now is become
a lot more transparent with respect to
where we're at
because frankly now we have a plan and
we feel good about our plans
the lieutenant general urged americans
to trust and take the vaccine he also
told us he expects operation warp
speed's distribution plan
to remain the same regardless of who
wins the presidential election
a lot of important information in there
tara thank you